and finally new rule the party of Reagan
has to explain how it has become the
party of Putin while real time is on our
break last month the infamous P tape was
finally found it's a high-definition
video of a press conference in Helsinki
and and it's irrefutable evidence of a
Russian ho and his name is Donald Trump
and like most hoes he always sounds
terrified when he's with his pimp
President Putin was extremely strong and
powerful in his denial today and what he
did is an incredible offer he just said
it's not Russia I will say this I don't
see any reason why it would be yeah this
is like after 9/11 if Bush stood on the
rubble at the World Trade Center and
shouted into the bullhorn bin Laden is
innocent and the FBI will hear from all
of us soon yes the President of the
United States is a traitor but being
Trump a man who's never been faithful to
anything but himself that is not such a
surprise but how did Russia flip an
entire political party and not the one
that was supposedly soft on Russia 87%
of Republicans say Trump should invite
the dictator who keeps attacking us to
the White House to stay probably and
Melania said he can have my room
of course part of this is due to the
Republican Party now being a straight-up
cult Trump can claim that when he said
would he meant to say wouldn't and
because every day is oppositeday now the
rest of the party says makes perfect
unsent to me would is wouldn't and being
friends with Russian thugs is repeat
after me
good not bad that's a good thing not a
bad thing not a bad thing that's a good
thing not a bad thing it's a good thing
not a bad thing that's a good thing not
a bad thing good not bad good
so that's part of the answer but for
such a fundamental shift for an entire
party there has to be something more
going on here and I think there is I
think the dirty little secret about the
Republicans and their newfound love for
baseball apple pie and Mother Russia is
that it's about race last year last year
and Coulter tweeted in 20 years Russia
will be the only country that is
recognizably European as far back as
2013 Matt Drudge called Putin the leader
of the free world David Duke described
Russia as the key to white survival
today's Republicans what's left of them
do not like the melting pot in Russia
that pot don't melt Russia is one of the
last places on earth to say [ __ ]
diversity we're here were white get used
to it I remember going to London in the
80s and everybody was white
the closest thing to an afro was these
guys
but now London looks like New York and
the mayor is brown and the princess is
even half black in the recent World Cup
the French national team didn't look
like the old France and it looked like
the new France Germany let in a million
Syrians the fatherland is now the
brother land you know how many Syrian
refugees Russia has taken in - Martin
Sheen has more refugees in his pool
house this is what the Russian army
looks like the ballet their basketball
team looks like the team that plays
against the Globetrotters they have a
drink called a White Russian that's
actually the whitest drink there is
let's see I want to get drunk but I also
want a glass of milk
Russia is a hunky oasis and Republicans
lammott Russian kids don't learn the
words to disperse Ito and a Barack Obama
does not become the president of Russia
wingnuts used to accuse Obama of being a
foreign agent who took over America but
when a foreign power actually did take
over America and it was the proudly
white one their response was come right
on in to the members of the grand old
party Russian meddling in our elections
isn't a breach of national security
it's just white people helping white
people what Republicans call governing